what happened down there Isabel if you
found yourself underwhelmed by the
simplicity of the original Halo Wars RTS
back in 2009 it's understandable that
you might be skeptical of Halo Wars 2
but with total war developer Creative
Assembly introducing the series to
Windows 10 PC and launching new
multiplayer modes there are many
features players can look forward to
there's a lot of promise surrounding
halos latest project but there's still
one big question will halo wars to
appeal to both Halo fans and RTS gamers
that is what you're up against James
cutter
we need to run as far and as fast as we
can
it's been a little over a year since
halo 5 Guardians introduced a new
narrative to the Halo universe and fans
of the series will be happy to hear that
unlike the original Halo Wars which was
a prequel to halo combat evolved halo
wars tues campaign will navigate new
territory within the halo lower
recognizable faces from Halo Wars one
will return along with familiar places
the series has visited in the past but
this time around the spirit of fires
krill will wake from cryo sleep and be
thrust into the current halo timeline
post halo 5 Guardians this means that
the halo wars 2 campaign will have a
meaningful impact on future installments
possibly even halo 6 from new villains
to new vehicles the sequel's narrative
should lay the groundwork for future
halo first-person shooters but when it
comes down to it halo wars 2 is an RTS
first and foremost and what halo fan
doesn't feel satisfaction commanding
massive armies of halo units come on let
the carnage BD the original Halo Wars
refined the console RTS genre but the
controller plays serious limitations on
the overall management and control of
the battlefield so the game's migration
to PC will be a welcome addition for RTS
gamers who are accustomed to the level
of control a traditional mouse and
keyboard has to offer using these tools
to navigate the halo landscapes and
manage different control groups michaela
wars to feel more like a classic RTS
experience in addition Creative Assembly
expanded the existing console controls
ensemble studios introduced back in 2009
by adding control groups to the d-pad
and other helpful console commands it is
now much easier to command armies with a
controller chill trust
kakim running broth halo wars 2
describes itself as an RTS for everyone
in the sense of the game is easy to
understand for beginners but still
offers a more comprehensive experience
for seasoned experts new game modes like
blitz and strongholds offer alternative
arenas for players that want to dive
into the action quickly while classic
modes like death match and domination
return to satisfy players who enjoy a
more traditional style of play and this
all ignores the fact that if you want
you can plant both platforms and
experience it from both sides via xbox
play anywhere with a month left to go
until release there's plenty we have yet
to experience in Halo Wars 2 but from
what's been seen thus far the game seems
to be headed in the right direction
beyond being a much more detailed RTS
than its predecessor halo wars 2 will
push the Halo universe forward and
continue to introduce Halo fans to the
strategy space the game shows promise
but the true testament to the game's
effectiveness will be in whether it can
introduce Halo fans to the world of
real-time strategy or draw adamant
strategy bands to the Halo universe to
see our thoughts on Halo Wars to be on
the lookout for gamespot's full review
when the games released and if you're
watching on youtube be sure to subscribe
I
[Music]